oh that's good I'm On Top of the World
Imagine Dragons
celebrating its Global anniversary
including 35 years right here in the U.S
to Mark the occasion the Magazine's
taking a closer look at how travel is
evolving with special editions on the
future of travel they're exploring space
tourism for one I was trying to think
what that cover is I was just help me
understand what that cover was we just
looked at the development of floating
cities and the rise of so-called Eco
hotels only on CBS mornings Conde Nest
Travelers Deputy Global editorial
director that's Jesse ashlock joins us
here in the studio welcome
thank you first cover yeah what was that
cover is an art project by a British
artist named Vincent Fournier we felt it
really embodied the spirit of the future
of travel and uh and what we want to
talk about in this issue and of course
space is part of the future of travel
and I believe more than I did when we
embarked on this project that space
tourism is going to become something
more and more people will do space tour
space tourism you say is closer than we
think what is it exactly well you may
have heard about Richard Branson and
Jeff Bezos going suborbital during the
pandemic and they've taken some people
up and they've taken some people up yeah
um I think uh you know William Shatner
has gone up
um and it's obviously something that's
only available right now to the one
percent of the one percent you know a
trip to space will run you well into six
figures but if you think about it that
was true of air travel a century ago
that was true of cruise travel a century
before that and so it doesn't last long
yeah and then they come back well I'll
tell you astronauts rhapsodize about
what's called the overview effect when
you're up there and you see the shiny
blue marble and you think about the
fragility of life on Earth Earth and you
come back you know a changed person with
a new missions who make life on Earth
better um that's the utopian Vision but
do you see it being affordable because
right now it's crazy crazy expensive I
think that prices will come down as more
spaceships get built more motherships
get built um I think that it will likely
remain in the luxury sphere but it will
become more accessible to more people
and I think that there will also be
other ways of having the space
experience in this issue we covered a
French company called orbitay that does
a kind of space experience on Earth they
have a um like space camp basically and
they're building a campus in the US that
will open in 2024 and you can go
suborbital you can do research you can
have an experience that's very similar
to what you would do on Blue origin or
on Virgin Galactic and then afterwards
you can go back to your luxury hotel and
have some champagne and caviar so you
know that's a way of doing it without
blasting off if that's not your bag yeah
and without it being too daring because
it is quite an adventuresome thing uh
okay I want to talk about floating
cities though uh what is the floating
city what's driving the idea behind a
floating City so if you think about it
floating cities have been around for uh
centuries even Millennia I mean
indigenous populations from Peru to
Cambodia live on them and we've been
planning cities firms they're pretty
yeah that's Busan South Korea that's a
proposal there that um big an
Architecture Firm from Denmark is
working on um and so floating cities now
I think they combine a desire for a sort
of planned Utopia with a need for
climate resilience and in a port city
like Busan South Korea or uh they're
building one in Saudi Arabia called neon
that's going to extend into the Red Sea
and it also speaks to Logistics how soon
could we go to something like that
within the decade in Saudi Arabia yeah
you go hotels Eco hotels are um a really
really rapidly growing uh uh segment of
the of the hotel market and the reason
why is that Travelers are demanding them
more and more I think during the
sustainability was important to the
traveler before the pandemic and then
the pandemic happened and we saw those
pictures of the clear skies and the
clean Waters and we recognize you know
the impact that we were having with our
travel but we need to travel you know
and we also recognize the impact that
not traveling had on economies all over
the world that are super super dependent
on tourism and we need to go out there
and see people and learn about the world
I mean it it uh promotes tolerance and
understanding it's true but but for
people who want to go somewhere by going
nowhere there's also virtual reality
that is true another part of the issue
uh so virtual reality and um now the
metaverse um I think of it this way so
you can it fulfills this sort of
perennial traveler dream of going
somewhere in innocent right
um without having to get on a plane but
you also don't you I mean you can have
interactions in the metaverse that's
part of the point but you can't really
interact with flesh and blood people and
have these kinds of authentic meaningful
on-the-ground experiences so I think of
it as kind of a try before you buy all
right thank you Jesse
we'll be right back you've already tried
it yeah travel